hey everyone i'm john coogan and welcome
to the third installment of my guide to
startup fundraising
last week i talked about the different
types of investors and how to decide
which ones might be ideal for you
today i'm going to talk about how to
manage a fundraising process and
actually meet prospective investors
as always the best way to raise money is
to build a great business
and if your company is making its
customers happy growing the customer
base significantly every month
and has a giant pool of potential
customers it'll be easy to meet
investors and they will be fighting to
get time on your calendar
let's start with the founding team's
role during fundraising since you're
optimizing for growth
not strictly fundraising it's important
to avoid letting your whole team get
sucked into the fundraising process
designate one founder to lead the
process and let the other founders stay
focused on growth so the company doesn't
stagnate while you're raising money
the quickest way to close an investor is
to show big growth in between two
meetings
the ceo should always lead the
fundraising process even if
all founders are equal shareholders this
is because investors expect the ceo to
set the vision for the company and they
want to hear about that vision directly
but that doesn't mean that the other
founders can't help out everyone should
introduce any potential investors that
they know to the ceo
and be available for in-person meetings
with investors who plan on writing large
checks and want to meet the whole team
even though it might feel like you can
make fundraising go faster by having
every founder work on it full time
the cost of slower growth and the
inevitable confusion around what
allocations have been promised to what
investors make the ceo-led approach
vastly preferable
now that you have the ceo clearly
leading fundraising you need to focus on
going as broad as possible with your
outreach
instead of finding one investor having
an introductory meeting then a follow-up
meeting then getting a decision
and then finding the next investor to
talk to aim to talk to all of your
investor connections
simultaneously inevitably you will need
to do some prioritization so when it
comes to prioritizing meetings during
fundraising you should think about the
expected value associated with each
investor
an angel investor who's very likely to
move quickly but only writes small
checks
might have the same expected value as a
vc who could lead the round
but is less likely to do so ideally you
should spend your time with investors
who move quickly and lead rounds
and always try and avoid small angels
who require lots of meetings to get to a
decision
that's a total red flag if you're having
trouble assessing investors before you
reach out to them
be sure to check references with other
entrepreneurs that they've worked with
in the past
and get a feel for who would have the
highest expected value for your round
i find that setting up a spreadsheet to
track outreach is really helpful at this
stage
you don't need anything fancy like a
full crm just a list of everyone who
you're in contact with and where they
are in the pipeline
here's a template that i like to use
while fundraising start by listing every
investor you know along with anyone who
works with investors regularly
as you take meetings with investors
update the sheet to reflect whether or
not they have committed
and how much you expect to receive from
them be sure to add notes and to track
when you ask for additional intros
introductions are the best way to meet
investors and there are a few different
varieties of intros
the best introduction is always one
between a well-known investor
who is committed to your round and then
a new potential investor
after that getting an intro to an
investor through a founder who has
raised money from that investor before
is great the startup world also has a
few different types of super connectors
like lawyers and reporters
and they can connect you to investors
too although those referrals usually
hold a little less weight
angel list and other fundraising sites
can help you connect with a broader set
of investors
but it can be hard to get initial
commitments there and you'll have a much
easier time on those platforms if you
already have a big name
investor attached to your round although
it can be tempting to take every intro
that's offered to you
you should avoid taking intros from
investors who have passed on your round
since that's a negative signal
if an investor passes and offers to make
an introduction to someone
make a note of that person's name and
then make a connection through a
different channel
if you can't get an introduction or
don't know any investors cold outreach
can work surprisingly well when done
carefully
you never want to spam investors and
send generic emails
instead focus on finding investors who
are specifically interested in your
industry
and send them a thoughtful email tell
them where your company stands today
and why it's a fit with their most
recent investment thesis
most investors have blogs or twitter
accounts where they talk about what
they're interested in
and this is a great way to make sure
that they can be valuable to your
company and that they're worth your time
to try and pitch
investors are hoping to find amazing
companies that no one knows about
so don't be intimidated by cold emailing
investors who you know would love what
you're working on
another way to increase the
effectiveness of your cold outreach is
to scale back what you're asking for
your goal is to get a meeting scheduled
where you can give a full pitch
but offering to start with a 15 minute
phone call or even just a short back and
forth over email
is much easier for an investor to say
yes to investors hear pitches all day
and don't want to waste their time
so allowing them to start with a short
call or exchange of questions
reassures them that you can concisely
describe your business
it can be super helpful to start
developing relationships well before you
plan on fundraising
one of the best ways to do this is to
engage with investors and other experts
in your field on social media
sites like twitter medium substack and
quora are all common publishing outlets
for investors
well you shouldn't waste too much time
browsing it's great to stay on top of
what the vc community is thinking about
your industry
since you're working on your startup
every day you'll often have additional
context and be able to add to the
conversation
establishing yourself as an industry
insider can help you connect with
investors organically
it's a delicate balance though you don't
want to pick fights or come off as a
cocky know-it-all
so stay positive and informative in some
cases if no one is talking about your
industry at all
it might make sense for you to start the
conversation yourself that's exactly
what we did at soylent
in 2013 silicon valley wasn't talking
about food nutrition or even consumer
package goods very much
so our ceo rob reinhart started writing
about our product on his personal blog
his writing did well on hacker news and
he was able to gain a following
this made conversations with investors
much easier because there was already a
discussion about the industry going on
and we were at the center of it once
you've figured out how to connect to an
investor
either through an introduction or cold
outreach you need to pitch your business
in the most succinct way possible
this is typically called an elevator
pitch and should cover the key points
you want an investor to remember
you need to highlight what you do how
fast you're growing what makes your
company different from competitors
and how large the market is cold emails
and warm intros should include
at most a few sentences about your
company so you need to make them count
avoid jargon heavy lingo and focus on
describing your business in plain
english
there are a few good ways to summarize
what you do and ultimately this will
depend on your specific business
but here are a few templates that can be
helpful you can use an analogy to
compare yourself to a popular business
that everyone understands
this usually takes the form of x for y
and there are a bunch of popular
examples of this
youtube was originally flickr for video
airbnb
was ebay for physical space and baidu
was google for china
just make sure that investors actually
know the companies that you are drawing
comparisons with
if you use some obscure company that no
one knows about you'll just confuse
everyone
another common format is focusing on the
problem and the solution
so the stripe founders might say we
allow developers to integrate payments
without headaches
before stripe it was common knowledge
that payment integrations were
notoriously difficult
so clearly describing the value
headache-free payments
in relation to the users developers
makes it easy to understand what the
company does
in addition to your elevator pitch
you'll also want to include a link to
your product or landing page
but you don't need to send a deck
immediately if an investor asks to see a
deck after scheduling a meeting
it's fine to send one in advance so they
can ask better questions
but avoid sending the deck before
scheduling the meeting since you don't
want them making the decision
on whether or not to meet you based on
your deck alone
once you've got a meeting on the books
you'll need to be ready to share your
vision for the company through a deck
having a clear slide deck will make sure
you hit all the key questions and have
some extra data or examples that can be
referenced by the investor after the
meeting
in my next video i'll go through how to
build a great fundraising deck
so be sure to hit the subscribe button
investor outreach is just the first step
in pitching your company
so cast a wide net and network as
broadly as possible
preparing a long list of potential
investors will make the rest of the
process
much easier this allows you to run an
efficient and competitive round
so really spend some time generating
good leads
if you think i missed anything please
leave me a comment below i try and
respond to every question i get
and if you enjoyed this video a like
rating is always appreciated
thanks for watching